[VIDEO GAME BEEPING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Storing
and querying massive datasets
can be time-consuming
and expensive
without the right hardware
and infrastructure.
Google BigQuery is an
enterprise data warehouse
that solves this problem by
enabling super-fast SQL queries
using the processing power
of Google's infrastructure.
In this episode, will go
over BigQuery Qwik Start,
a quick 30-minute lab
that introduces you
to Google BigQuery.
You'll notice on Qwiklabs
that you can take
this lab in one of two ways.
You can use the web UI
or the command line tool.
Feel free to take the lab you
feel most comfortable with,
or take both if you
want to see how it
would work in either scenario.
In the lab, you'll
query a public dataset,
load custom data into a
table, create a new data set,
preview your table, and then
query your custom dataset.
These labs are
designed to give you
a little taste of
the many features
available within Google Cloud.
Even if you've never used GCP
before, you can take this lab
and get started.
Next up on our
quest is Bigtable--
Qwik Start a Command Line.
A quest is a series
of related labs
that form a complete
learning path on Qwik Labs.
Completing this quest
earns you this badge
to recognize your achievement.
You'll be using a student GCP
account to work on these labs,
but if you're ready to
get your own GCP account,
here's $300 to get you started.